You may have heard a lot about DNA.
DNA stand for Deoxyribonucleic Acid.
Individual pieces of DNA formed the gene,
and then collectively they comprise the entire
genome.
DNA was identified about 100 years ago by
Friedrich Miescher, who was a chemist in Germany
at the time.
He was trying to get cell nuclei out of bandages
used in hospitals, which are full of white
blood cells that contain a lot of DNA.
And he wanted to know what a chemical composition
was.
So he found that there was a lot of this stuff
that he called, at the time, nuclein and it
took a very long time to realize that this
nuclein actually was important for life.
People thought it was just some kind of structural
molecule that held the nuclei together.
It is not until Watson and Crick figured out
what the structure of DNA was, that people
realized that it was a molecule that could
carry information.
Inside the cell, you will most commonly find
double-stranded DNA, in which two strands
intertwine to form a double helix.
The most common form of the DNA double helix
is also called B-form DNA.
We can unwind the double helix so that we
can see the chemical structure inside.
Each strand is a polynucleotide, meaning the
strand is made up of many individual units
called nucleotides.
A nucleotide has three components: the five-carbon
sugar, a phosphate group, and one of four
possible nitrogenous bases - adenine, guanine,
thymine, and cytosine.
The nitrogenous base is always attached at
the 1’ carbon of the sugar.
If we count from there, we can see that there
is a phosphate between the 5’ carbon of
one sugar and the 3' carbon of the neighboring
sugar.
The sugar is called deoxyribose because it
is missing a hydroxyl group at the 2' carbon
which is present in ribose.
Because of this, nucleotides in DNA are called
deoxynucleotides.
Nucleotides attach to each other in the DNA
strand by phosphodiester bonds.
The phosphate group of one nucleotide binds
to the 3' oxygen of the neighboring nucleotide.
Thus, we can see that the sugars and phosphate
groups make up the DNA backbone.
The carbon numbering is key to describing
the directionality of the DNA strand, 5' to
3'.
Looking within the sugars, there is an intrinsic
orientation difference between the two strands.
On the top strand, you can see that the 5'
carbon of each sugar is on the left and the
3' carbon is on the right.
The opposite is true for the bottom strand.
Reading left to right, that makes the top
strand orientation 5' to 3' and the bottom
strand orientation 3' to 5'.
Keep in mind that this double-stranded DNA
is still a double helix and we have simplified
the representation by flattening and unwinding
the helix here to better see the atomic structure.
Although the nucleotides come together through
covalent bonds in the backbone, the two DNA
strands interact through non-covalent hydrogen
bonds between the bases.
Each base forms multiple hydrogen bonds with
its complementary base on the opposite strand.
Bound together by hydrogen bonds, each unit
is called a base pair.
The hydrogen bonding contributes to the specificity
of base pairing.
Thymine preferentially pairs with adenine
through two hydrogen bonds and cytosine preferentially
pairs with guanine through three hydrogen
bonds.
Thymine and cytosine are called pyrimidines,
characterized by their single ring structure,
and adenine and guanine are called purines,
which have double rings.
The geometry of the AT or TA and GC or CG
base pairs is the same, allowing for symmetry
and base stacking in the helix.
This mostly has to do with the distance between
the backbones and the angles to which the
bases attach to the backbone.
Other base pairs, like GT, for example, do
not have the same geometry, cannot form strong
hydrogen bonds, and disturb the helix.
The double helix structure of DNA is highly
regular.
Each turn of the helix measures approximately
ten base pairs.
In addition to the hydrogen bonding between
the bases, the stacking of the bases also
stabilizes the double helix structure.
These - interactions form when the aromatic
rings of the bases stack next to each other
and share electron probabilities.
The regularity of the helical structure forms
two repeating and alternating spaces, called
the major and minor grooves.
These grooves act as base pair recognition
and binding sites for proteins.
The major groove contains base pair specific
information while the minor groove is largely
base pair nonspecific.
This is because of the patterns of hydrogen
bond acceptors and donors that proteins can
interact with in the grooves.
In this way, the DNA can be acted upon in
either a sequence specific or non-sequence
specific manner, allowing proteins to position
themselves correctly in the genome to carry
out their designated tasks.